and having steve ballmer as the owner
Doc Rivers very much a player friendly
coach the whole front office structure
this team is built for success for many
many years to come and I'll be watching
it it's gonna be very strange to turn on
a clipper game next year for me and once
they went why are we supposed to be
there honey we're late for the game well
I respectfully Ralph give you the final
word in this and you you've earned it a
tremendous career and like I said
earlier an honor for me to do games with
you this year and experience that but a
wonderful career and you and Joe nothing
but the best in the future well thank
you very much Don you're welcome to have
your family come up and visit us again
you did that I come on yeah we would
love to have you have you back for a
return it well so that is it for me I'm
gonna join the guys up outside for a
final salute to this marvelous 2018-2019
season a season to remember one that I
will I guarantee you never forget I
guess the thing that I'm gonna miss most
of all is the fans except our fans are
are such a unique breed so many people
will come I've been a fan since 1984
when the team moved here I've been a fan
since 1989 when they drafted Danny
Manning or I've been a you know a fan
since that that Darius Miles a Quinton
Richardson Corey Maggette II team in the
early 90s or I've been a fan since 2006
the Elton Brand Sam Cassell team
everybody's got their different point
where they all of a sudden kind of found
this the Superman wagons kind of fun fun
to be on and you know when Blake Griffin
left Chris Paul left DeAndre Jordan left
you thought you know maybe people would
jump off the bandwagon and in clipper
fans don't I mean they stick around
because they've been through some hard
times and I think this year was great
for them because if the expectation was
low they over achieved in these clipper
fans appreciated that let's take a look
at some of the highlights from this
amazing la clipper season saw them win
48 games in the regular season which
just
13 14 15 more than anybody possibly
dreamed they would a be able to
accomplish but they did it was quite a
season